hello is someone there uh you're at a
Darkness Retreat what the hell is a dark
master train oh never oh yes a Darkness
Retreat and you must be my conscience
yes I love player empowerment but this
season Aaron got maybe two empowered so
as punishment we're brainwashing no
strongly suggesting that he joined the
Jets no offense no offense is literally
our problem fine I'm going to the Jets
so long as he wants us to sign the ghost
of Jordy Nelson get McAfee hired at WFAN
give them that Joe name of the jacket
much like my personal hero Scarlet Witch
after she turns evil I have eliminated
all player autonomy and trapped them in
the grand iron Heights of my own making
I mean we renovated
isn't that the same Gridiron Heights but
with a monorail what no it's a new day
in Gridiron Heights we're restructuring
with some old favorites and exciting new
places just win baby the tofu was a
fumble Josh McDaniels is a football
genius oh and you're gonna love the
direction we take Derek Carr in this
season
I'm fixing to get me some etouffee down
there about a quarter now somewhere
players were easier to reprogram I mean
convinced than others uh Jalen some
people were talking saying you'll
never play for the Dolphins
they'll show them before long we'll have
the gray iron Heights I've dreamed of
with exciting new characters
[Music]
of course I'm short my name is
we fit together like coffee and Maya
hmm I think I could mold you some
characters will have to be retired good
night Ezekiel I love you the very most
but I didn't retire you could just
resign me I'm happy we got to an
agreement
it's normal good and free of Scandal you
can't make me sell Kitty dancing
this is your fault for not having an
agent
they said they're sending me to a team
Upstate where I'll have plenty of room
to scramble they'll be back for us any
minute now
any minute Baltimore's gonna come
calling just you wait next year is my
year
I'm Ryan Leaf get me out of here